but as films became more more and more
uh successful they became more and more
expensive
and so any film that you see
when i first started making movies my
producer a guy who taught me about movie
making said any movie can be made for
any price you can make the hundred
million movie dollar movie
for five million dollars fact today with
an iphone you can make it for 50 grand
and you can make the 50 grand movie for
100 so people are making comedies which
is two people standing in a stupid room
talking to each other for 200 million
don't make any sense so what happens
because they have so much energy and so
much
money to distribute what happens is it
attracts parasites
you're in l.a still you are in la still
anyone that listened to the last few
minutes is going wait a minute how is
this guy in hollywood in la
saying these things how can you make a
living still how can you get gigs
can you get can you walk into caa and
they're going to still talk to you i
mean how how has that been for you
well as we used to say in chicago i
drove my car here i didn't come on the
bus
so uh
i've
continued to have a
pretty wonderful god-given career as a
playwright they're doing my plays all
around the world
in fact they got to play now on broadway
with lawrence fishburne and sam rockwell
and darren chris an older player of mine
called american buffalo and as far as
getting hired in the movie business i
i'm too old to sit in a room with 12
guys named jason
[Laughter]
you know my agent they're all named
jason
but how but how about that i mean just
living in la right now i mean after two
years of of covid and just the way the
the whole industry has collapsed i mean
that was one of the reasons there were
many reasons i left l.a yeah but it was
also that there was it wasn't just the
covid crazies everything and the crime
and the homelessness okay we could do
all that it was just that it felt that
there was nothing cool about it anymore
whatever whatever was cool and creative
about la
felt completely gone to me
well you know cities grow for a reason
and when the reason is gone they get
repurposed when i first first worked in
new york a million years ago i was
working in greenwich village and
anything south of houston street was a
slum absolute slum
there were people who were squatters who
were artists and homeless people living
in those um
lofts that used to be a manufacturing
district and eventually the city came in
and said okay okay you artists you can
live here forever we caught 200 bucks a
month you can rent so i got friends
whose grandchildren are living in lofts
for 200 bucks a month that would sell
for 30 million dollars okay so now what
used to be lofts and manufacturing
becomes artists so as always
along with our brothers the homeless the
bohemians come in and repurpose a
neighborhood and because the bohemians
come in and repurpose a neighborhood
then the restaurants come then the shops
come so now soho becomes the prime
shopping district
on the east coast and people come from
all over the world to shop in solo gets
repurposed right what happens then
black lives matter and the rat the
writers come in and say [ __ ] you
they
clean everything out
what does the new york police do about
it
nothing
so what you see is what started off as
an industry catering to the shipping
trade in new york then became abandoned
and then became squatter a place for
squatters both the homeless of the
artists and then became a shopping
district and is now
going
yet again going to become a slum
so this is the history of the world so
how do you liken that to l.a what do you
think is going to happen to la and i do
have to tell you that every time i
mention california on my show
gratuitously i have to put five dollars
into this jar and at the end of the year
i'm giving a couple thousand bucks away
to someone who lives in california to
move to florida so if you're looking to
move
i might have a couple couple thousand
for you
what do you think is going to happen to
la
well first i want to say about miami's i
used to go to miami all the time in the
50s with my dad who had business down
there we fly down there and i'm still
trying to get the zinc oxide out
off
yeah it's sunny but it's all right
what's going to happen to let's happen
to la here's the thing
just as there's no
there's no business like no business
there's no when you do away with the
theaters and you do away with the the
possibility of um
independent production
and
there's no reason for the film industry
anymore to be in la
i mean they came out here because there
was there was a sunshine and they made a
bunch of crap every year they made a
bunch of crap on a couple of movies that
were memorable and a couple of people
snuck through and made something
beautiful and a couple of people snuck
through and made a fortune and sometimes
the two people were the same and
sometimes that they weren't but
so that the industry grew up here first
because it was sunny and second because
they uh
they were fleeing the uh edison company
which held the patents in new york so
the bootleggers came out here to make
movies so the studios just like soho
grew up around these bootleggers right
and then they gave rise to this
incredibly magnificent community had 5
000 people working as as musicians and
sent their kids to graduate school here
right 10 000 people working as actors
all of the professions and so forth were
a middle class that supported the film
industry
but as films became more more and more
successful they became more and more
expensive
and so any film that you see
when i first started making movies my
producer a guy who taught me about movie
making said any movie can be made for
any price you can make the 100 million
movie dollar movie for five million
dollars fact today with an iphone you
can make it for 50 grand and you can
make the 50 grand movie for 100 so
people are making comedies which is two
people standing in a stupid room talking
to each other for 200 million dollars to
make any sense so what happens because
they have so much energy and so much
money to distribute what happens is it
attracts parasites
they suggest like if you're rich you say
well i have a housekeeper how about that
oh
richard i have two housekeepers oops got
to keep an eye on them i'm going to have
a household manager oops got to keep an
eye on them because they have friends
and delivery i'm going to get security
oops now i'm going to get us so
eventually
the superstructure brings down the ship
right there's more super there's more
there's more restaurant critics than
cooks or um customers so there's no
reason for the business to be here
anymore in fact most of it isn't but yet
we have these huge like you mentioned
caa uh
people who if they all went away nothing
would change in the movie business
but they they spawn
other parasites
right
the agent gets a sub agent and the sub
agent gets a blah blah blah and then
people get a manager to deal with the
agent no one's ever exposed with a
mammoth told me what manager does
so there's all of this superstructure
but there's
but who's working if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell